a reality show set in the remote
wilderness in Scotland was taken off the
air but here's the weird thing
the producers didn't tell the
contestants until months afterwards this
really happened yes my god no one told
the contestants the contestants sat in
the wilderness for months thinking their
show was still on the air I'm not making
this up they thought it was still in the
air and it had been canceled and I've
been canceled for a long time that's
just insane is really quick you know
that reminds mission didn't you produce
a reality show awhile ago we're like two
guys we're gonna live in your desk or
something it was like that it was about
someone about the death right oh my god
yes yes I I forgot a lot of stuff so I
forgot I produced a reality show called
two guys one desk I think we have the
narratives yeah yeah it was for TBS the
whole idea was two guys were supposed to
I thought this was a great idea you guys
supposed to spend a week right here
inside my desk and I like I said I do so
much I host this show I completely
forgot about it I just Oh Jeff what what
was the deal with that show was that
show canceled yeah like two years ago
that show wait
the show was kissing two years ago did
you did we tell the guys why didn't we
tell the guys
oh no not a second
what happened did I win Oh what no you
didn't win look where's the other guy
who was in there with you uh I ate him
like the first week this is terrible
being in there all that time must have
been awful for you
hello isn't all that I I got married you
got married well where's it where's your
wife I hate her too okay listen it's
awful how long was i down there you were
down there two years what'd I miss
well let's see what's going on not a lot
Donald Trump is president
if that's terrible we completely ruined
that poor guy's life
Jeff's got his new catchphrase hey
you're the guy I know you come come on
do it again do it again do it again wait
to my mom we just ruined his way
you